roberta mitzola was elected president of
the european parliament with 458 votes
the maltese conservative takes over from
president david cecily after his sudden
death on the 11th of january she will
lead parliament until the 2024 european
elections
french president emmanuel macron set out
france's priorities for its six-month
presidency of the council of the eu
he discussed with mep's ways to face
challenges like the climate crisis and
the digital transition
in an eu survey 61 of people said they
had come across illegal content online
parliament voted on the digital services
act which aims to better protect users
from illegal content targeted ads and
harmful algorithms
after 18 months of investigation
parliament is calling for an overhaul of
how animals are transported
it recommends limiting travel time
better protection of young or pregnant
animals and stricter enforcement of
current rules
[Music]
meps discussed the situation in
kazakhstan where at least
225 people have been killed in clashes
with police during anti-government
protests
[Music]
you